the sun's core
is shrinking but as its core shrinks
the sun itself grows larger
and it will continue to grow
until one day it engulfs the earth
how long can you survive
what will happen to the oceans
and will other planets be affected
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the sun swallowed the earth
every 1 billion years the sun becomes
10 percent hotter but here on what if
we're going to take billions of years
and condense the action
into one month get ready because we're
going to be moving
really fast this time instead of
one billion years it would only take
four days for the sun to become 10
hotter
this means you'll see the earth engulfed
by the sun
in just one month that is if you're
still around to witness the final event
on day one you'd be blissfully unaware
of the tragedy about to befall earth
maybe it's a little hotter but that's
just weather it happens
but by day four space agencies across
the globe would be sounding the alarm
bells
by this time the sun would be about 10
percent
brighter and hotter
and while 10 doesn't sound like a lot
it will be the beginning of the end for
us
as the sun heats up more and more water
from earth's surface will
evaporate into the atmosphere this will
increase the greenhouse gas effect
causing global temperatures to skyrocket
all of a sudden it will become very
humid
and very hot
but the sun's high-energy light would
bombard the atmosphere
splitting those water molecules into
hydrogen and oxygen
earth will begin to lose its water and
you won't be able to escape
the lethal radiation on earth's surface
if you want to survive you'll have to go
deep underground
but even under a protective layer of
earth's soil
you won't be safe for long
by day 16 the sun would be almost
40 percent brighter our planet's oceans
will boil and there won't be any
moisture left in the atmosphere
the beautiful lush earth that you grew
up on will become
a hot dry barren rock
around day 20 the sun would run out of
hydrogen
so instead it will start to burn helium
in its core
the sun is now a red giant star and
would expand
rapidly while losing its mass
the sun's gravitational pull on earth
would be weakened
and our planet would begin to drift away
from the expanding sun
but not far enough
according to researchers klaus peter
schroeder and robert c
smith the earth would only have moved
about 0.0002
astronomical units an astronomical unit
is the distance between earth and the
sun
while earth is moving away from the
encroaching sun
the red giant would grow up to 1.2
astronomical units in radius
the sun would be larger than earth's
orbit
it would swallow the planet whole
once it's inside the sun's atmosphere
earth would
collide with particles of gas and spiral
inward
and earth wouldn't be the only casualty
of the expanding sun
mercury and venus would be vaporized
the rings of saturn would melt
pluto would become much warmer and if
there
is a liquid surface and a thick
atmosphere on this distant dwarf planet
it might even become inhabitable
unfortunately 30 days doesn't give the
human race enough time to prepare for
such a catastrophic event
but if we had more time like billions of
years worth
we could come up with an evacuation plan
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you